hello in this video i explain to you
in a simple way the test for a
sample
the test for a sample checks
whether the population differs from a
specified value
so we have our sample
from the population and we want to
know whether this sample differs
significantly from a  reference
value differs the difference is measured by taking the mean value from this
group and comparing this
mean value with the
reference value the question is so are there
statistically significant differences
between a random mean
value and a fixed value so of
course let's look at examples
let's start  with the first example
you would like to find out whether the
perception of health among female managers
in austria differs from that of the
general population. for this purpose
, we asked 50 female managers about their health recommendations.
accordingly, our population
is the  managers in austria and
we want to compare this group with
those of
the entire population for this we need a reference value for the perception of health of the entire austrian
population, e.g. from a specialist journal
we would then like to compare this value with our
total population of austrian
managers the second
example is a technical one  example you
want to find out if the
screws your company produces are really ten
grams on average to test this
you grow 50 screws and
compare the actual weight with
the weight they should have therefore
our population is all
produced screws have this
produced screws  we took a
random sample and now we want
to check whether the screws produced
can really count on average,
like the last example from medicine,
a pharmaceutical company promises that
a new drug will lower blood pressure in
e  in a week at 10 a
you should find out if this is
correct for this you compare the
observed reduction in blood pressure of
25 subjects with the expected
reduction of ten units you all
these three examples contest for a
sample before we just one
sample in 13 cases
we have the sample of the 50
managers here we have a
sample of the 50 screws and
here we have a sample of the 25
subjects and
we now compare this one sample with a given
value here the given value comes from
the entire population  here the
given value comes from the target number how much
a screw should actually weigh and
here sternbeck given value from the
promise of pharmaceutical companies that
the blood pressure is reduced by ten units
so we now come to the
prerequisites and the hypotheses for
a random test
must calculate the considered data from a
random sample come from have metric sky
level and be normally distributed
so short version the prerequisites
are that we need a random sample
metric sky level and the
data must be normally distributed
so we can now come to the hypotheses
the null hypothesis is the mean of
the population is equal to the
given  value and the alternative
hypothesis is the mean value of the
population is not easy the
given value
therefore the new hypothesis is there is
no difference and the alternative
hypothesis there is a difference
both are non-directional prostheses now of
course we can also
set up directional hypotheses in
this case would be  the new hypothesis the
mean value of the population is
nevertheless the size or
smaller depending on the direction in which
you test those of the specified value
and the alternative hypothesis would then be
the mean
value of the population is smaller rela  ntly larger than the
specified value, therefore, the set-up
case is simply checked, is there
a difference yes or no,
and in the case of the directed hypothesis
is checked, is one of the two values
or smaller than another value and n
w let's do it all with an ex
mple  the average
score in the statistics test at a
university has been 28 points for years
this semester a new online
statistics tutorial was introduced now the head of the degree program
would like to know whether
the success of your studies has changed positively since the introduction of
the statistics of
your studies the question is so does that have an effect
online statistics have a positive effect on the
test results in this
case we have a directed hypothesis
because we do not want to know whether there is a
difference yes or no but
we want to know whether it had a positive
influence, i.e. that the
test results are better than
before accordingly it is u  Our
hypothesis is that the online statistics tutorial
has no or a negative impact
on the success of the exam. The alternative
hypothesis, on the other hand, is that the online
statistics tutor has a positive
impact on the success of the exam.
To check this, a
sample of twelve students was
taken, so we have about twelve here
female students and the number of points for the exam grade
if we calculate the average here from now on
we get 2 3
633 now of course we
already see that 32 33 is greater than 28
points but what does that mean exactly
now we can just say it fits the
online tutorials  a positive
influence exactly that's not
that easy we need
the test for a random sample for this now it
could also be that this result
just came about by chance
with the help of the perpetrator we can also
say how probable this result
is therefore we have  the null hypothesis
online statistics do ha  t no or
a negative influence on the
test success if the new hypothesis
is correct, i.e. the online statistics have no
influence, then we should actually get
28 points or something smaller
now it is of
course a random sample and in
this random sample the result in
our case has a scatter  we now
get 32,33 out the question that the
perpetrator can answer for us is how
likely it is that by chance
a result of 32 33 or something greater will
come out although the zero
mortgage actually belongs, i.e. if the
online tutoring actually has no or a
negative influence  how
likely is it then that we will get a
result and 32.33 or something greater
this
probability is very very small
usually five percent is fixed they
say it is so improbable
that this random sample comes from a
population with a score of
28 or less and the  null
hypothesis is rejected and  now
we look at how you
can calculate the tts for this we first need,
as just
indicated, that the significance level is so
at the end of the day we want to check whether
the probability that this
result or a more extreme one occurs is
greater or less than 0.05  if it is
larger, the zero will be retained
if it is smaller, the new hypothesis will be
rejected then we need the number
of samples values this is 12 in
our case next we ne
d the mean value of the score this resul
s in 32 33 and we also need
he standard deviation  the
standard deviation of these
values is 5.47 this stand
rd deviation is the estimated value
for the population and now we wa
t to calculate the so-called standard error
of the mean the standard neith
r of the mean is calculated by divid
ng the standard devia
ion by the square root in our case we ge
that  5.47 by the root of  12
which is equal to 1.58 from here we can
now calculate the tea value the tea value
is obtained by taking the mean value -
the reference value ie 28 and dividing it
by the standard error of the
mean value in our case
we get 32 33 - 28
1.58 that gives a value of
2.75 last but not least we need the
degrees of freedom the degrees of freedom are
given by n - 1 equals 11
now we have everything we need
to calculate the ph value the value just gives us
exactly  the probability of how
likely it is that if the
hypothesis was is like getting a result of
32 33 or something greater so
we have our significance level the degrees of
freedom and tnt value we have
a directed hypothesis so we
want to check if anything is greater
if we  we want to look at the distribution
so we know we are
in this five percent range for
this we can now
read off the critical value in a table w  we
set the iphone level at 0.05
so here we are looking at 0.95 1
this is simply given by 1 - the
significance level we have
degrees of freedom of 11 so we are in
this row and this column and
we get a critical value
Out of 1.79 six out of 1.79 this critical issue
is less than our calculated value
therefore we are in this range
as our p value is less than 0 5
and thus less than the specified
significance level of 0 05 in which case
we can support the null hypothesis  discard
and we can assume that the
newly introduced statistic disturbance has a
positive influence on the statistic
test results now i would like to
show again what would happen if you had
an undirected hypothesis instead of a directed one
in which case
these values will remain the same as befor
still the significance
level of 0.05 you would have the
degrees of freedom of 11 and a value of
275 now in the f  All of the undirected
hypotheses, however, we would split that 5
percent left and right
, so it would be 25 on the
left and 25 percent on the
right. Now that means that
if we want to read the critical issues,
don't look at 0.95  but
at
0.975 our critical value
is now 2 2 0 1 this value
is still less than 275 and in
this case our hypothesis would also be
undirected we will reject the zero
hypothesis i will now show you
how he did the test completely  you can easily
calculate online for this please go
to tape de click on the statistics
calculator and add your own data to this table
i will just use
the example and your that in
the statistics we want to calculate a
perpetrator so click we also
examine test  we want the number of points
so we click on number of points and
now we can enter our test value
here the test wi  rd so the value with
which we want to compare this group
is 28
and now we already get the
result for the perpetrator is here we have
the descriptive statistics again
so we have a mean value of 32 33
a standard deviation of 5.74 and a
standard  error of the mean value of
1.58 and below we see the
results of the culprit is we
get a ph value of 0 019 for the
unjust case we have now
calculated a directed hypothesis so
this value has to be divided by two
this value is natural  less than
the specified significance level of
0.05 and thus we rejected the null
hypothesis so
here we get exactly the same result as
when we calculate the test plan i
hope you enjoyed the video and
see you next time